you are relaunching the iconic Loveline
franchise yes I am how did this all come
together this is it really just up my
alley just being a feminist and being
very sex positive and having people call
in and ask questions and I have a sex
therapist dr. Chris Donahue that's on my
my talk show he's gonna be doing the
podcast with me as well I'm very open
with my sexuality I don't hold anything
back I'm not judgmental and you know
there's really nothing that anyone can
call in and say that I probably haven't
heard already did dr. drew send a nice
Bluff saying I have not spoken to dr.
Drew yet you know hopefully I will soon
I want to play a little rapid-fire
around I'm gonna ask you some questions
oh my god and you're gonna tell me what
your snap judgment what your advice
would be for me okay what is the best
pick-up line that a girl can use just
compliment and always referred to the
guy or girl by their first name once you
introduce yourself how many dates should
a girl wait before sleeping with a guy
she can sleep him the first night she
could sleep with him a month later a
year later it's not gonna change the
fact that he may or may not cheat on you
or look at you differently or you can
still sleep with a man the first night
and and still get married it really just
doesn't matter what's the best way to
get back at a cheater um success okay
yeah I love that always what's the worst
thing a guy can say after sleeping with
a girl you're over that don't mean that
guys never say that that's so mean
horrible rude